welcome to exploring computing
today's video is the internet of things
so as i suggested at the end of the last
video when we were talking about
mesh edge and fog computing more and
more devices that are not thought of as
traditional computing devices are being
put onto the internet
and this network of
non-traditional computing devices is
sometimes referred to as the internet of
things
and so let's take a quick look at some
examples of devices that fit onto the
internet of things so you have a better
sense of exactly what i'm talking about
i think as a consumer probably the most
likely place that you are to run into
these
sorts of devices are in the concept of a
smart home
so if you've got a smart light bulb for
example
that would be considered internet of
things why would you want a smart light
bulb well
if you have smart light bulbs you can
control
their colors so you know if you've ever
shopped for light bulbs there's the do
you want the bright white
do you want the soft white do you want
the warm white
well if you've got a smart light bulb
you can just kind of change the
rating on the fly you'd be like oh i
have some friends coming over
i want to make it a little bit warmer or
you know i'm trying to do some artwork
on
the table and i wanted to to have
pure white light so i know exactly what
it is i'm drawing great i'll go ahead
and crank that up
and you can also control the light bulbs
for uh
you know if you're remote uh and you're
not there and you want it to make it
look like you're there you can you know
control those remotely
and so there's there's a bunch of
potential reasons why you might want to
have smart light bulbs
as to whether or not it's worth it to
have smart light bulbs and what security
risks are well
that's kind of up to you we'll talk
about security risks a little bit later
in this lecture
um you can have sensors connected to the
internet
these can be combined with smart
speakers for example so
if you've got a house with smart
speakers and sensors as you move from
one room to the next it can turn
the speakers on and off and the music
that you're playing could follow you
around from one room to another
thermostats can be connected to the
internet
where you can process the data and
control it again remotely
and you know do some analytics on it so
there's a variety of different devices
that are
being connected to the internet and i
suspect this will
this trend will continue and more and
more
devices will just seem natural
your kids will probably think it's
totally normal whereas i'm still a
little weirded out we have smart light
bulbs
all right uh here's another example
internet of things this is probably one
of the best uses i've seen
so when i was in the stanford dorms as a
resident fellow they actually put the
washers and dryers onto the internet and
so this was actually
really handy because it meant that
usually the washer dryers are all in the
basement they were in the first floor
for our building but
you know if you're in uh your room and
you want to know whether or not you can
do your laundry
you just check the internet page and
it's like hey
dryers one and four are available so
great you go grab your
laundry you drag it downstairs you know
that there's an available washer there
and it's also pretty handy in terms of
seeing when you're
when your load is going to be done so
you can check in and say
it'll say oh you know you put your
clothes in washer number four and
washington number four has 15 minutes
left so
um i thought this was pretty handy and
you can imagine in a big building or a
building where
there's a lot of uh use of the washer
and dryers and it's kind of hard getting
getting access to them having this sort
of information it actually is quite
handy
um transportation is another area where
we're getting more and more
internet of things types of capabilities
so just in a car
you know clearly the navigation system
or the entertainment system
you know that could be part of the
internet and in fact many of us just use
our cell phones for that so
that is part of the internet um there's
some discussion on
whether the engines and uh
actuators for things like controlling um
how the engine works uh whether or not
those should be part of the internet of
things i think there are some potential
concerns with
uh security in terms of if everything in
the car is part of the internet
i think it makes a little bit easier to
hack um
you can have the cars communicating with
each other so each of the individual
cars could be part of the internet
um and this actually could be really
useful in terms of
you know we can get different data sort
of like waze does right now
where all the cars are talking to each
other and so they can tell each other
what the traffic conditions are so one
of them could say
hey i was just going across the bay
bridge 15 minutes ago you don't want to
go that way it's just a complete
nightmare
go go a different direction you can
embed
sensors into the roadways and turn the
roadways into smart systems and then
using the internet they could talk to
the cars
here's another really cool use of the
internet
you can have smart parking meters where
if you're looking for space
all the parking meters are part of a
network and they all have little sensors
telling whether or not they're available
and you can just be like hey i need a
parking space
where is the nearest parking space that
is currently available and
it'll connect in with your smartphone
and you just
look on your little map and you go to
that parking space so i think that's
really cool
you can also connect it into paying
remotely
being reminded hey you've only got five
more minutes on the meter
do you want to uh up up put out a little
bit more money there and get another a
half hour or another hour
so i think i think some of these can be
potentially quite useful
so another area where uh the internet
can be used is
in industrial processes and uh this
actually forms a separate area that's
sometimes referred to as the industrial
internet of things
so we can take a standard industrial
process and start instrumenting it by
adding different things in that process
onto the internet
we can add sensors that are on the
internet
we can have controllers that can
actually be actuated
via the network we can control inventory
management using rfid tags i'll talk
about those in a little bit more detail
in a minute
um if we've got a fleet of vehicles we
can
connect them all to the internet and
keep track of those and i will have to
say personally
i'm fond of delivery vehicles which
are on the internet and we can see where
they're coming mostly because
um delivery often has big trouble
finding my
apartment and so knowing when they're in
the area is actually pretty useful for
me
um and we can control we can add
security
like motion sensors cameras and lights
onto the internet as well so
these are all um areas that you know
they're certainly
moving into this area and i think again
we'll see more and more of this
all right let's go back to this idea of
rfids these are radio frequency ids
generally the devices with the rfids
themselves are not part of the internet
but the device is reading the
ids will be part of the internet of
things so an rfid is similar to a bar
code so um you know if you've been to
the grocery store and i'm sure you've
all been to the grocery store at one
point or another
those little barcodes that they used to
run at the checks
checkout stand to see what the uh the
particular item that you're purchasing
is and what the price of them is that's
the barcode
and so an rfid is very similar to a
barcode in
that it provides a unique number or a
number that's associated with a
particular product
but the difference between an rfid and a
barcode
is that we need to optically scan the
or so for the rfid i don't need to
optically scan it
i just need that rfid tag to be within a
certain distance of my rfid
reader and the actual distance for the
rfid reader does vary
depending on there's a bunch of
different competing standards but
on the low end you can read the rfid
tech from about a meter away
at the high end you could actually read
them as far as 200 meters away
and in a lot of cases the rfids don't
actually have their own
power they're going to be triggered
remotely by
the device that's that's scanning the
area for them
so uh one of the most compelling
scenarios i've heard for using rfids is
inventory management
so currently if you've ever been in a
store or you've been part of the staff
of a store that's doing
inventory you've got all the employees
out and they're
running around down each the aisles
pulling all the items off the shelf and
counting them all up
and it's extremely time consuming
measure um
and it you know it's it's annoying and
time consuming
well with an rfid on each of the items
you don't need to do that anymore all
you need to do is you need to take an
employee with an rfid
reader and just walk down each of the
aisles of the stores
and the rfid reader will sort of ask
each of the boxes on the shelves hey
what's your id number and i'll count
them all up and you'll be done so
inventory counting will go from a huge
undertaking to a very simple
quick undertaking the main reason why we
aren't doing this right now is the rfid
prices are still a little bit too high
um the low end is around 10 cents per
rfid
so you know if we were to do this at the
grocery store or
at the drugstore um it would add 10
cents to the cost of all the items and
so
uh that's still fairly high but the
first time i gave this lecture it was
actually 15 cents per rfid so it does
seem to be coming down in value
and you can imagine once it's down to a
couple pennies per item
it's probably going to be worth it to
switch over okay so
there are some concerns that to note
about the internet of things
one of them is you know how are these
devices connecting to the internet so
most of the devices we use that connect
to the internet
either use wi-fi or bluetooth wi-fi
takes a fair amount of
energy so that's kind of problematic
unless this device is actually plugged
in
there is a bluetooth low energy standard
and so this is the choice for a lot of
internet of things
devices this also potentially adds a lot
more devices to the internet so
if you start counting up how many
devices you already have i'm sure you
have a laptop
you've got a cell phone you might have a
tablet i do
you might have a bunch of game consoles
your television might connect to the
internet so that's a fair number of
devices but once we start adding a whole
bunch of other devices like
your oven's connecting to the internet
your refrigerator is connecting the
internet
your heaters are connecting the internet
it starts adding up pretty quickly and
we are already running out of ipv4
numbers so
this would really accelerate the move to
ipv6 you'll recall from our discussion
on the internet that
um ipv4
uses a set of four numbers between zero
and
255 and that there aren't enough numbers
using that standard so ipv6 is a
standard with
many many more combinations you hear
maddie barking in the background it's
because there's a dog outside that's
barking and she's
she's all excited about that okay the
other concern about
internet of things and i guess this goes
along with maddie barking there
uh is that i think there's a lot of
security concerns with internet of
things and there's a bunch of reasons
why
you should be particularly careful with
the internet of things
one issue is that a lot of times the
internet of things they're trying to
keep the device cost down so
you know anytime you're keeping the cost
down that means you're potentially
shortchanging a security
and so that is a bit of a concern i
think another reason why i have concerns
about the internet of things is a lot of
times
uh the cool internet of things stuff
that comes out it's some somebody has
this idea for hey wouldn't it be great
if this device
was on the internet and so they go ahead
and
and set it up but they don't actually
have any security people they aren't
familiar with security issues on their
own and maybe they don't have the money
to hire somebody who's a
specialist in security so you know i
would say
be cautious like if you see some random
kickstarter and you're like that seems
like a really cool idea
but it connects the internet like do you
trust them to have good security
you also need to remember to update your
internet of things devices
and this isn't something that a lot of
consumers are thinking about i mean
who thinks about keeping their light
bulbs updated all the time
so let's take a look at a couple
examples where internet of things
devices have failed
so smart light bulbs have been hacked
and you might be thinking well if
somebody takes over my light bulb what's
the worst that can happen
but these are considered potential ways
to get around
your security you can can hack
somebody's light bulb remotely
you are now in their internal home
internet and so that may give them
access to things that
and make it easier to access things that
you don't want them to whereas if they
have to go
directly through your router your router
might actually have better security
so one suggestion that i've seen is
that you can keep your internet of
things devices on a guest network
so a lot of wi-fi routers have a guest
network and then a regular network and
so you could put your internet of things
devices on
your guest network although that may uh
that may
impact the convenience of accessing them
and exactly what you can or can't do
with them
um internet of things cameras have also
been found
vulnerable to hacking so you know if
you've got that camera in your home
think about where you're placing it
think about what would happen if a
hacker were able to
to get access to it um i know a lot of
security experts who
have the cameras on their laptops
covered up
um one internet of things company smart
locks actually bricked when
they did an update in this case it
breaks
such that the locks were always open
it's kind of unclear to me whether
that's better or worse than having the
locks always locked
but um yeah people were not able to lock
their homes
so that's kind of a problem and i think
internet of things also provides a lot
of
privacy concerns so well
i think the internet of things there's a
lot of cool interesting
fun stuff that's coming out related to
the internet of things and i'm sure
we're going to see more and more of
these things as we move forward
you know do be a little bit cautious
think about
who these different companies are that
are creating these devices and whether
or not you trust them to have good
security
and whether or not you think that
they're concerned about your privacy
all right that's it for today i'll talk
to you all soon